the arguments for approaching life in a
grave serious and unsmiling mood are
overwhelming
we are clearly a profoundly wicked
species we continually perpetrate
monstrous suffering on one another
our greed and viciousness know no bounds
our minds are fickle and largely out of
control no one gets through existence
unscathed and every day is bad until
eventually the worst of all happens
the only people one could imagine
smiling through this kind of Horror Show
would be the still too innocent or the
actively deluded and yet one of the
order sounding conclusions we might
reach after having had our fill of every
kind of awfulness is that there might
still be a way to live
light heartedly amidst catastrophe not
because we don't know about the
unjustified pain the miserable errors
and the imperfection of everything but
precisely because we do know because we
know it all so well and have had enough
of ruminating on despair this is the
laughter that comes not when one has
never really cried but when one has
cried for years when every pretty hope
has been trampled on when one has made
some properly dreadful mistakes and been
repaid amply for them and when one is
fully considered ending it all but then
decided at the last moment to keep going
not because of anything one can expect
of oneself not because one holds on to
any standard belief in a good life but
because amidst the shitshow one can't
help but notice that the sky is a
delightful as your blue but there's a
bath cello concerto to listen to and
that there's a sweet four-year-old
currently holding on to her mother's
hand asking how ducks sleep at night and
so despite everything the loneliness the
shame the compromise the self-hatred and
the sure knowledge that the agony isn't
over yet one turns to the light and says
a big rebellious opsin
it joyful yes to the universe which
naturally doesn't give a damn sometimes
well-meaning people try to get others to
share up by telling them that they are
beautiful that they deserve good things
and that they have a share of the divine
in them bless such efforts and those for
whom they work but for the rest of us
there might be another way this based
not on sentimental bromides but on
staring down the darkness and refusing
to let it terrify us we might build
ourselves up by accepting with grace
that naturally and non-negotiable we are
total idiots others are mostly horrible
and almost nothing ever really comes
right and yet and yet we're going to
keep at it anyway
we become the sort of people who
understand that rearranging the deck
chairs on the Titanic would not have
been a waste of time because of how nice
the band would have sounded and how much
time there really was all things
considered before the icy water started
a lap at one's black-tie trousers and
how crucial it was to let those last
joyful notes ring out in the clear
Arctic night what lies behind this
light-hearted approach isn't naivety
it's the lightness that comes from
registering every kind of heaviness and
transcending it we can pick up on what's
distinctive in this attitude by
comparing two masterpieces of art one by
Velazquez painted in 1632 depicting the
most sorrowful moment in the Christian
history of the world the other made in
1979 by Monty Python showing us the
crucifixion of a nondescript every man
with a truculent determination not to be
moan his fate unduly velázquez is
classically tragic but Monty Python's
closing song brazenly tackles the
business of dying on a cross and plays
it for laughs life's a piece of [ __ ]
when you look at it instead of plunging
us further into feelings of sorrow the
mood is mocking and utterly committed to
refusing gloom always look on the bright
side of life purse your lips and
ever whistle this strategy of defiance
insists on squaring up to the grimness
and then asserting control over it
through mordant dryness and cynicism in
the Middle Ages a tradition arose of
condemned people on the scaffold turning
to the crowd and making a witticism
about their situation commenting on this
gallows humor Sigmund Freud recounted a
man being led out to be hung at dawn
saying well the day is certainly
starting well when aristocrat in the
French Revolution on being ushered up to
the guillotine then a brand new
high-tech killing machine looked up at
it's complicated workings and asked are
you sure this is safe rather than being
slowly noir dad by sideways glances at
the truth the gallows humorist insists
that they will not be silenced by it
they roll their sleeves up grab it
tenaciously and remove its sting through
comedy true light heartedness begins
with an appreciation of one's utter
cosmic unimportance and nullity nothing
we have ever done said or thought
matters in any way it's only the
monstrous illusions of our ego which
give us an impression that we count and
then torture us that we don't count
enough furthermore no one will ever
particularly understand us or lovers
properly and that isn't a personal curse
but an ironclad fact of nature which we
would do well to stop kicking against
and to be constantly disappointed by
everything we deeply want either will
not happen or will be unsatisfying when
it does we must stop crying as if any of
it really mattered or there ever was
another way we must pity ourselves and
then change tack the tragic view is too
obvious being miserable is too
predictable
now let's surprise ourselves with a
little irresponsible laughter the kind
it can take a lifetime of sorrow to
perfect please comment like and
subscribe and take a look at our shop
for more from the school of life
you